. There are new reports that Donald Trump
is all of a sudden significantly worried and
panicked about catching Corona virus himself.
And the context is terrible polling for Donald
Trump against Joe Biden in 2020.
Political failure after failure, after failure.
The White House is putting in place more and
more precautions to try to protect Trump from
the virus.
We've seen Trump publicly move on from the
virus.
It's all about reopening the economy.
Trump returned to greatness, transition to
greatness.
All of that stuff.
But the reports from inside the White House
are that Trump is much more worried than he
has been at any point about catching the virus
himself.
Now, we know Trump is a known germophobia.
He's that's been known about him for a long
time.
He's been doing rallies, though.
He's been pretending everything's good, everything's
fine.
But now he's reportedly panicking.
So what's happening is Trump is sending out
not just security detail with advance teams,
but also sort of like germ cleanup details
where they are determining, OK.
This is Trump's bathroom for this event.
We're scrubbing an ultra sanitizing the entire
thing.
Publicly, they've said, oh, everything's so
good.
Then at the White House, we're not low.
We're no longer doing temperature checks and
regular testing for everybody at the White
House.
That is true.
But the people around Trump are still being
temperature tested.
Temperature checked and covered, 19 tested
all the time.
You now have a ton of Secret Service that
are quarantining after two of them caught
the virus, sometimes surrounding the Tulsa,
Oklahoma, rally of I guess it was a week plus
ago, 10 days ago.
Now we know of a senior Trump economic official
who was in the Rose Garden with Trump last
week who now has the virus.
Their name is not being released.
Is it Larry Kudlow?
I don't know.
But Peter Navarro, it's not really clear who
it is, but we know about that.
What I don't understand is if Trump is really
convinced that hydroxy chloroquine or as he
says it, hydroxy chloroquine prevents corona
virus.
Why not just keep taking it right, like if
he ever was really taking it.
And it protects him from corona virus if he's
so worried.
Why not take hydroxy chloroquine?
It's another example of how what Trump says
publicly is the opposite of what happens privately.
Testing isn't that important, says Trump.
And yet everybody around him is tested every
single day.
Meanwhile, he's regularly golfing.
Now, I don't actually believe that Trump catching
Corona virus would be that bad for him politically
unless it killed him.
That what I mean by that is his own followers
aren't likely to abandon him because he catches
coronavirus.
They've not abandoned him with the testing
fiasco.
They've not abandoned him.
Over fifteen cases will soon be zero in April.
They've not abandoned him over.
It's going to wash through and go away like
a miracle by the end of the month.
If they've not abandoned him for that, why
would they abandon him?
Because he catches the virus.
On the other hand, the people who recognize
that Trump has failed on the virus.
They should already not be voting for him.
And I can't imagine their mind would be changed
by Trump catching the virus either.
Do you disagree with me?
Let me let me know.
Last thing, in the midst of all this, there
are rumors, again that Trump has Corona virus
and that that's why we've seen him tweeting
recently, but not actually in public.
I don't even know that that's true.
I mean, we saw him golfing recently.
Would he golf with a mild case of Corona virus?
I don't know.
What I do believe is that if Trump did get
Corona virus, but it wasn't serious enough
to put him in the hospital.
I don't believe the White House would tell
us.
I believe that the White House would avoid
for as long as is possible, admitting that
Trump has the virus again unless it leads
to him being in a hospital for days.
I think if Trump gets a mild case, we don't
hear about it at all.
If they can get away with it, let me know
your thoughts.
Remember, I am now bookable on Cameo at Cameo
Doc Slash David Pakman or just search for
my name.
Indiana The David Pakman Show David
Pakman Datong.